we should probably kick things off with
like the news that was out last night
um about grayscale so i can just like
quickly
tee that up for you guys but basically
we had the
grayscale investments application to
convert its 13.5 billion grayscale
bitcoin trust
into a spot based etf was denied by the
sec on wednesday night um guys you want
to break this down for us they're suing
the sec right yeah they are without time
time right
enough people apply for an etf and you
deny deny deny with no uh real reason to
deny the etf then eventually someone's
gonna come after you and say what the
hell and that's exactly what grayscale
did well the unfortunate part right is
that this uh was opened up or started
initially so you could track the price
of bitcoin right in a different way than
just buying bitcoin uh initially on spot
price and what it's turned into now is
it trades at a somewhere between 25 30
discount uh depending on the day which
obviously is not protecting anyone
especially if they're buying it today
relative to the price it's just not
tracking bitcoin at all now anymore yeah
and uh it's unfortunate because we've
seen other products approved futures uh
you can actually short bitcoin on
futures now via etfs uh so i think it's
only a matter of time before this does
happen but i think at some point people
expected it would have happened already
yeah and the ceo he was on cnbc this
morning um on squawk box um with melissa
lee and um as you mentioned they filed a
petition with the appellate court in dc
and basically um
um grayscale's ceo said that they
vehemently disagree with the sec's
decision here um specifically pointed
out like he said like the sec was acting
arbitrary and capricious
by continuing to approve bitcoin futures
etfs as you point out um joe uh while
continuing to deny spot etfs is there a
precedent against issuers like grayscale
is there
it's been a busy 12 hours for the
grayscale team
of course last night getting the sec's
decision we were of course very
disappointed but as an organization we
were ready
regulators do get sued
and it does happen frequently last night
after receiving the sec decision our
attorneys almost immediately filed a
petition for review with the appellate
court in dc and that starts the
litigation process contesting the sec's
decision which we of course vehemently
disagree with what is the core
thrust of that of that suit well we've
laid out these arguments throughout the
last couple of months leading up to this
decision um really looking at the fact
that the sec is acting arbitrary and
capricious by continuing to approve
bitcoin futures based etfs while
continuing to deny spot bitcoin etfs and
when you look at the administrative
procedure act which is really what
governs the way that regulators have to
govern they have to be treating like
issues alike and in this case they're
not they're actually discriminating
against issuers like greyscale who are
trying to you know bring a product
further into the u.s regulatory
perimeter
yeah so the sec's decision is like 86
pages i was just like looking at it
right now but i think
at the heart of it this is what i
kind of understand here's
it's clear that they knew this was uh
this was one a possibility and two
probably yeah i think i don't know what
like the betting odds were but they were
this was the favorite by far that this
would happen and hence why they were
prepared to file a lawsuit immediately
against them so the sec says that the
like in their finally they basically say
that they failed to answer questions the
sec's questions about preventing market
manipulation as well as other concerns
that's like
the heart of their issue i guess
yeah i mean it'll be interesting to see
this could take from what i read from
some of the etf guys from bloomberg last
night on twitter they were saying 12 18
months maybe it could play out uh before
we actually have a decision and there's
kind of a ruling on it uh so maybe
something gets approved even in the
meantime between then that's that's
certainly uh not tomorrow right so i
think uh it'll be interesting to see how
this plays out uh but i i think most
people expect the spot etf would be
approved at some point i'm interested to
see what they do when they actually if
they convert this into a spot etf only
for the fact that there's a bunch of
players waiting on the sidelines right
like anthony scaramucci refiled for an
etf with sky bridge there's a bunch of
other companies that have refiled
because they've gotten denied from the
sec so it's like when you approve one do
like we talked about this before do they
only approve one or do they actually
approve three to five of them to kind of
spread out the inflows a little bit um i
guess the sec will tell us soon well you
mentioned anthony scaramucci he was also
on cnbc i don't know if we have the clip
um guys of that but he kind of
his new an acronym for the sec is
stopping economic creativity i think
that was
i think that was uh what uh the mooch
said i don't know if we have a clip on
that the mooch
well you know it's it's an affectionate
uh nickname but um you know nick battia
he's also like a friend of the show here
and he was on just recently and he
writes an amazing um newsletter
basically macro stuff in bitcoin but on
the bitcoin lair and i mean he pointed
out that the sec has rejected like a
bunch of spot etfs of bitcoin as you
guys also pointed out hey anthony as we
await president biden's uh
debate uh over bitcoin
etf and crypto we've been uh talking to
the ceo of grayscale this morning
obviously very frustrated with the sec's
decision
what do you make of it
listen it's it's a missed opportunity
for the country uh we've had the mantle
of financial services leadership for 100
plus years and the fact that the sec is
moving in this direction where the
europeans are allowing for a cash etf
the canadians are allowing for a cash
etf just a huge missed opportunity you
know i the sec now stands for stop
economic creativity and i think that is
a terrible thing for the country uh
moreover they won't even give you the
regulations andrew you know they they've
hired more people in the enforcement
division and so the venture capital
community the crypto community is like
okay so we'll find out what to do if
you're investigating us
why don't you put down in writing what
the regulations are and the rules are
for all law-abiding citizens and will
happily abide by the rules and so this
vagueness and this uncertainty i think
is hurting the united states
and it'll hurt our intellectual capital
and our capital formation going forward
so i hope they stop it
are they really stopping economic
creativity though like there's etfs like
this isn't like an etf isn't creative
it's there's tons of etfs for tons of
commodities on tons of different assets
right the question is why would you have
the other
types of etfs um and not one like this i
think that's what also like i was just
mentioning nick battia points out like
in his he says that this is a baseless
reason for vetoing greyscale spot etf
bid um first of all he says grayscale
has no has had no solvency issues
whatsoever in the nearly nine years of
gbtc trading publicly um he points like
out the health of the balance sheet and
what not so
i guess like he also says like the sec
has no problem with synthetic bitcoin
derivative etfs sec has no problem with
a short bitcoin linked etf and so
according to nick it's illogical for
them to have a problem with a perfectly
solvent and reputable trust such as
grayscale taking a spot etf to the
market
i actually kind of like uh how this got
brought up and then that they sued the
sec only for the fact that there was a
theory going around that they that
grayscale didn't want to convert to an
etf based off their management fee that
they get from gbtc which is around two
percent and that management fee would go
down if they converted it to an actual
investment they're not getting any new
inflows so at some point right they have
to open it up to be able to acquire or
get more new capital inflows so i think
i think they do want to do it and
obviously it seems like they do with
they keep filing applications they're
obviously upset now they're suing the
sec i don't think they would be doing
all that for theatrics and i think uh
what we're going to see now is uh at
some point you would expect it to get
approved for all those reasons they've
already approved futures and if you do
have futures then you got to do the
short et cetera now if you have the
futures you're going to do a spot maybe
they do that soon maybe they do it in 18
months maybe this decision accelerates
that timeline i don't know but it's it's
kind of unfortunate that it hasn't
happened already
any other parting thoughts
who are the sec's lawyers for this
what big guns do they bring in those
jokes is that the big winner here is the
lawyers right because uh they're gonna
get paid they're gonna get paid
regardless who wins yeah both sides yeah
um so let's move on um i think uh john
it's probably a perfect topic for you
since you're kind of our electric car
connoisseur but
um let's talk about electric vehicles
kind of like what's going on in the
space like the pricing there and then we
can get into some of the other kind of
fun things yeah so electric vehicles now
cost an average of fifty four thousand
dollars so we saw riveon saw tesla saw
ford sold gm saw a bunch of electric
vehicle companies go ahead and increase
their prices i think tesla did it around
six thousand dollars or so maybe a
little bit less uh but yeah so now the
average electric vehicle costs around
ten thousand dollars more in the initial
purchase than a gas combustion engine
yeah that's pretty good and the cars are
getting better too i don't know if you
guys saw but the uh the mercedes new one
it can go like it did 750 miles on a
single charge really have you guys
helped that's insane
it's a content car it's a concept caller
uh so they say they're gonna use the
tech for their other evs uh but at the
same time you know that's that's pretty
impressive that they're able to build a
car that does that do you guys have any
interest in having or buying an ev
i do i think the biggest uh points for
people to like get in like a bunch of
americans and other people around the
world to kind of get into evs are one
the infrastructure has to be there which
has been rolled out over the last three
four years the price point has to be
there so i think fifty four thousand
dollars for the average car is going to
be a little high um i think americans
probably pay from a study i saw a while
ago that was around like thirty thousand
dollars or so maybe twenty five thirty
30 000 for a new car um so the
infrastructure that and then look the
the pricing and everything like that
like you spend money more on the car and
then you get cheaper on the gas and
electricity part of things on where you
go uh but i think the infrastructure
things like they have to i think if
they're cheaper than regular cars
everyone's gonna have one yeah right
like it's just the incentive to buy it
cheaper they're supposed to last longer
as well yeah that could last longer that
is you know they're nice obviously
tesla's are nice cars uh they're gonna
look different at some point right i
feel like tesla's dominate the market
right now especially here in the united
states and you see them uh they all kind
of look the same but eventually you'll
get some kind of different
characteristics and stuff like that too
yeah it's just like it was like funny
well you know you think like okay uh
maybe with the elevated gas prices that
it might accelerate it but still i think
it's the price point there's probably
the deterrent and also like how long do
people keep their cars like i mean i'm
trying to think like i feel like my
parents probably had their cars for a
good while now yeah well it's also
replacing the battery on an ev is a lot
more expensive than put replacing like a
piece of an engine of a combustion
vehicle right so that's obviously the
big component of this is why are prices
increasing for evs it's because the
components that go into the ev car are
getting more and more expensive so where
do commodities and that sense well and i
think a lot of a lot of uh people
probably think about gas in the in in
the short term versus long term right
they're like okay it's five six seven
whatever it ends up getting to in
certain areas that you live in uh
dollars per gallon but a new car is
forty five thousand dollars right so
even though you may uh it may be the
good economic decision on a 10-year
horizon most people are just thinking
about kind of what happens today what
happens tomorrow uh and in a lot of
cases can't even afford those those
opportunities so uh if you're buying a
used car maybe the inventory isn't as
high as electronic vehicles and electric
vehicles and so forth uh so there's
probably a different few different
reasons but i think at some point like
if you're able to consistently get these
cars at a lower price point than new
models of gas uh combustion engine cars
the the market is gonna grow you guys
see the story about like um
flipping evs not not flipping them
physically like flipping them like a
house that's what you thought yeah
this is pretty wild like have you all
seen this uh yeah i mean
it uh uh makes sense though i read it
quickly this morning he makes like seven
to four thousand dollars each time he
does it so what does he do he buys okay
so this is um uh dennis wong he he lost
money on his first try this is in the la
times uh but he's learned from his
mistakes that's what the article says
but he's turned into an electric vehicle
flipper he made four thousand on his
third one he yeah he made seven thousand
in profit
um
oh he says he has a model s that he's
currently trying to sell
let's see i'm just like scanning through
here but
i guess like it's probably related let's
see
yeah probably just like the demand right
now for evs um car shoppers who are
looking i guess if you're in the market
for a new car you're probably looking at
the record fuel prices especially i
guess he's probably based in california
and also used car prices are already
elevated or they continue to be elevated
what's the wait period for like a new
tesla yes that's probably it like the
weightless
there was um in miami i'm not on it
because i never got invited on but
there's like um the telegram like miami
tech telegram and apparently this
according to my husband someone like was
like all cash offer like
like new tes like it was like less than
a month of tesla like i don't know what
they wanted like 70k or whatever it was
i don't remember but yeah good enough i
mean teslas right now are almost
appreciating it sounds like ev's because
of the wait period i treat it almost
like a rolex and not because of the
luxury part of things because there's a
wait list to get one you have to once
you get accepted to get one you put down
a small deposit and then you have to
wait another i don't know how long tesla
is but i know rolex's are like a year
sometimes even more um and then you have
the price appreciation you could sell it
right after if you don't use it because
people are on the waitlist and they
don't want to wait this is interesting
looks like the values have been going up
for these things too so
yeah i mean it's it's not uh necessarily
surprising to some degree right though
because you use rolex as an example uh
it's the same kind of kind of thing
that's happening right the demand for it
is outpacing the current supply and
whether rolex is intentionally holding
things back or there's just not as much
coming to market for some reason due to
supply chain constraints like there's
more demand than there is supply so the
price goes up yeah same thing that
happens with tesla because they have
this waiting period because people
aren't able to go buy them on the
primary market uh they're becoming more
expensive on the secondary market so if
you're someone like that that has access
to these vehicles or can find i don't
know how he's buying them whether he's
playing somewhere else or buying them
secondary uh it only takes you know one
person to go buy this asset and they can
appreciate so one um i'm just looking
again at this article it says there's
like a seattle-based startup that found
that
used electronic vehicles not
electronically electric vehicles sorry
early in the morning still need my
coffee evs have climbed 25 in price
since march 2021.
used ones used ones yeah
yeah i mean well uh i guess part of it
too is the overall market has climbed to
some degree used cars and generals was
at some point up in the mid-20s right so
uh it probably tracks that relative and
then when you think about electric
vehicles they're like the top tier of
the market relative to that so they
probably appreciate even more yeah
probably just like indicative though of
like the dislocations and the economy
right now like it's it's it was always
the case like you drive the car off the
law is like appreciates like i i bought
a jeep um
early march of 2021 and it was like you
couldn't get like when the supply chain
was just crazy you couldn't get one of
those and i was like oh the prices like
are going up on like the resale value of
those things
pretty crazy you'd be surprised what
people are willing to pay for something
when they can't actually get it
themselves right yeah so like what
premium would you pay for whatever it is
and it doesn't matter the item like what
premium would you pay for a microphone
for a computer if you didn't have access
to it so i interviewed jeffrey gunlock
um and he bought a used truck that was
like maybe like just slightly off like
what the original price would have been
had like eight thousand miles on it like
i guess but he paid more than he would
have paid way more and he was like he
was like and you know the guy with the
dealership was like you know saying i
got a deal right and i was just like
there's nothing worse than don't tell me
you're getting a deal when you don't
think so well i mean but no he actually
goes like i believe at the time he
probably was getting a deal just because
that was like when things were that was
probably spring 2021 yeah so things were
like really out of um whack but yeah
yeah well if you think about it too uh
teslas are are probably more popular
with the younger generation of consumers
uh who have been flushed with cash to
some degree over the last few years as
markets appreciated as these things
happened
and people are going to buy them and
when you have markets go up that much
over the single period of time whether
it's a year or two years uh asset prices
increase right and that's that's what
happened to tesla too yeah
um all right let's move on and talk
about what's been happening in the
economy again like we're finishing up
the quarter here but we should also just
note that this week we got some data
that the us economy um
shrank at an annualized place pace of
1.6 in the first quarter so that was
like the revised number that we got out
of the bureau of economic analysis for
their final estimate for first quarter
gdp um of course we'll find out what
second quarter gdp will look like um
once we get
into uh next month so we'll find out
more there but yeah i think like what do
you guys think of like what's kind of
been going on in the backdrop of the
economy is is anyone expecting us not to
be in a recession not to have two
consecutive quarters
like i expect us like it's gonna come
out and it's not gonna be surprising to
me yeah i don't think anyone's gonna be
surprised yeah i i think that's the
general way to look at it right is that
most people expect it's gonna happen
it's more around timing uh but no i
don't know what the odds are i think uh
yeah given kind of what's happened over
the last couple of years with the money
printing with the economic policy with
the federal uh reserves reaction and all
of those things i think that uh most
people are probably expecting it with
these aggressive rate hikes and where
asset prices are right now and declining
uh the real question is just like does
it happen this year does it happen early
next year does it happen further out
down the road how long are they able to
kind of withstand this thing and then
once it does happen how aggressive is it
and how quickly do we recover from yeah
how long does this thing last um and of
course like yeah i guess like everyone's
kind of focused on like will we be in a
recession and also the inflation still
kind of continues to be like the
the big story i feel like eight point
six percent have we peaked inflation do
we get a dollar we'll find out when we
have our next guest on like at least
find out you know his take on it versus
um what we think but you know we can
like also just kind of
narrow down on like stories within like
the economy what's going on and i mean
i feel like
this ceo i'm gonna mention
i don't i always like his like
commentary he's very forthright in his
commentary i find that when you talk to
ceos
they aren't always they always seem a
little bit more cheery and upbeat and
not super real but this was the rh
restoration hardware ceo
they did put out lower guidance
yesterday just for their um fiscal 2022
like net revenue growth and their q2
expectations but ceo gary friedman said
the following like he talked about the
deteriorating macro environment so he
says the tier the deteriorating
macroeconomic environment has resulted
in a lower than expected demand since
our prior forecast and we are updating
our outlook uh particularly for the
second half of the year and keep in mind
they had just reported earnings so they
had another forecast just a month ago so
they changed within the month
but he points out with mortgage rates
double last year's levels luxury home
sales are down 18 in the first quarter
and the federal reserve's forecast for
another 175 basis point increase in the
fed funds rate by year end our
expectation is that demand will continue
to slow throughout the year so you're
like hearing from
uh you know a big name retail ceo just
on like
his concerns for economic growth going
forward so i found that to be
particularly interesting he's the ceo of
what company again rh so restoration
hardware you know like the nice
furniture yeah they got good stuff i got
something so you got it you've got a few
other products no i don't it's true
above my price tag you know it's uh
that's probably why i don't know about
it above my line
just saying man they got good stuff it's
nice expensive yes oh so he also had
some more comments like this is the
thing like you're actually getting real
comfortable so he also says um while we
anticipate the next several quarters
will pose a short-term challenge as we
cycle the extraordinary growth from the
cova driven spending shift shed less
valuable market share as we continue
raise our quality so there you go some
quality and choose not to promote our
business while um while we navigate
through the multiple macro headwinds we
continue to believe our long-term
investments will enable us to drive
industry-leading performance over a
longer term horizon that's interesting
so they're going to like not while and
choose not to promote our business while
we navigate i guess it's pull back on
advertising i suppose that's what he
means there yeah but we've seen uh with
the tech layoffs that have happened
right across the board especially with
tech companies people have been getting
laid off but
advertisers and that's one part of their
business is where do they advertise
right so we were talking sports right a
bunch of crypto companies have gotten
into sports
but they've probably slowed down
advertising right like they may not be
regretting those 700 million dollar
deals that they did for like crypto.com
did for staples center ftx did for the
miami heat arena um but i'm sure that
that's gonna slow down some capacity and
probably across the board not just
within the crypto well and the way to
think about some of those partnerships
too is uh specifically with an industry
like crypto which is relatively new
right in the grand scheme of things to
most consumers that you're trying to
market to uh sam bankman freed the ftx
ceo had a good line about this uh that
someone told me and he basically said uh
we could do a couple different
strategies right if you're trying to go
market to customers you go to a bunch of
facebook ads you do google youtube all
these stuff right but they don't really
know who we are right so it's kind of a
waste of money you're probably not
seeing the roi that you would want to so
let's go do some of these big deals take
really big swings and make sure that
people know exactly who we are through
social media through uh the partnerships
that we're doing with teams or leagues
or sports organizations and then we'll
go spend a lot of money on the ads
because now they'll know who we are
they'll know what we do what we
represent and those other underlying ads
will perform much better than they
previously would have i saw binance did
kb lame and ronaldo yeah two big swings
yeah they said they uh they were able to
hire because they didn't spend any money
everyone was like well
that was a lot of money they also just
use a stock photo and put your ceo on it
yeah that's funny all right well joe and
john you guys are so much fun so thanks
so much for joining me today thank you